on march 15 2012 film courage sat down
with James and say young darling of the
Morgan Spurlock doc comic-con for a fans
hope this audio is an excerpt of that
press roundtable interview to find out
more about this amazing look at
comic-con and the fans that attend
please visit comic-con movie com just
decided no graphics in the film did did
you feel like you want to run out the
hall at that exact moment because of all
the attention on you or were you
disturbs your spot it was like as soon
as he asked it was like tears like that
was all that was going all is the thing
cuz it was so weird to me because he the
whole weekend had been acting so weird
and I wanting to get away from me and
wanting to hang out which was really
unusual because we always do everything
together so it was just like I think a
big relief I was lying opposed yeah
right i want to eat me yeah yeah but
yeah it it was like in the moment
you know even though there was kind of
so much attention around it it still
felt like it was kind of like this or
intimate yeah i was like just us two and
then you know had to update the face
facebook profile
question so you guys went to comic-con
did you have the intention when you were
starting to do this movie are you with
the casting process of proposing or were
you just like oh we're dating if you
plan to do this so so the there was kind
of a casting call on a Nicole like to
sort of like share us you know your your
stories and what you're planning to do
this year at kala Khan and I've been
thinking about the about proposing at
comic-con for for a couple months and
then it was just like yeah I should do
it let me I'm going to do and they sort
of like you know doing doing that the be
kind of sharing my plans with with the
sort of casting people was was you know
they got me tonight I I can't back out
of this now so yeah I just tell to her
then would you tell her about the doctor
what so what they asked if we could be
if we could do like a little odd
audition tape and I was kind of like
okay how am I good yeah how am I going
to play this with her and so what I told
her was that I just shared how we had
essentially started dating at comic-con
the year prior and you know they were
interested in following a comic con
romance I think I was more liable to buy
it because we work in like media like
yeah like the movie version you know
anyway so they have the comics person
the cosplay person will be like the
movie people right and we're like dating
right I think it's why I bought yes your
daughter boy
but yeah so if we film that we found a
taper we kind of talked about ourselves
and our interests in our relationship
and then I covertly and we did it in her
family's house and then I covertly like
privately like you don't a little energy
exactly the ignition certainly have you
guys seen the movie we have outside of
your story which one of the other
stories really really got to you which
was the one in your left hand oh I'd say
I tale for me it's Holly's story for me
it's a soldier yeah okay Oh dreams yeah
yeah we we can't stand to watch
ourselves Oh golly I want to make a lot
where we're not in how did you guys
initially meet at comic-con like we
discuss other was like he's having a
girl's piano or well we actually I mean
we were both going to school at UC Santa
Barbara I was just starting my masters
and she was finishing her bachelor's and
so we actually met on on campus and but
we discovered that we were both going to
comic-con in a couple weeks and so so
yeah the summit some of the the coverage
has claimed that we met at college isn't
quite true but like it was only had our
first date yeah it's like yeah let's
meet up and like you know it's just like
we shouldn't get along we've got a
common side oh there's this girl I have
to meet up with I don't know if I can
hang out
okay Treecko yeah and then he was like
yeah let's hang out yeah yeah yeah I
just seemed either school didn't have
Kevin Smith marry you and what was the
actual wedding and hollywood life was so
we we follow up with Kevin Smith's
people and they sort of offered us he
actually has a podcast where he marries
people married and it's like in this
like adorable little block black box
theater in LA yeah but like we wanted a
way yeah we felt forever for our for for
both of our families since we had done
this kind of geekiest engagement
possible we might want to have one
aspect of our marriage that was it was a
little more traditional we we both lived
in Santa Barbara so it's like well it's
just we live in a destination wedding
destination so but we for our honeymoon
we actually yeah this is pretty gay p so
Harry Knowles who runs an equal news
invited us to his but nomicon in awesome
yeah so the button of a thon is a 24
hour film festival at the Alamo
Drafthouse in Austin and then it's it's
24 hours of films you haven't seen like
films that I mean even come out yet some
like classic films that he just wants a
guy you know exposed to the world or or
your ass down and you don't leave for
solo
but you can go to the bathroom and yet
the graph has I actually serves food you
know yeah deep-fried and disgusting
smell real gross so that was our that
was our very geeky how many yeah what is
your guys's primary key Curry's like
whatever you turn out each of you um and
together keep getting me into Star Trek
cuz i try i get start tracking I grew up
on the next Shari yeah absolutely yeah
but I you know I've seen it all and uh
so that's that's my primary key curry
and probably Firefly yeah forever
absolutely I most your friends like you
or
where you are I'd say we have a pretty
good range of friends oh yeah like a
friend who I I would claim our geekier
than us but that's true this is an
interesting point I think that being is
nerd it's just so for now like a reason
to check that is the new cool like
anything like I know that well so we'll
compute our generation cool ask you
about the ring in the more debate skills
I don't all the jokes stuff that were
made in the doctor i right Peter Jackson
or Elijah would have you met anyone I've
Elijah Elijah Wood why don't what has
had a number one we were like he coats a
button on the pond so I was like
standing like in line behind them
waiting to go into theatre no freaking
out but I was like I can really cool and
I sat down and I start talking really
loud about I saw like you would any so a
little bit in the Rings bubbeleh and he
turns around and he wasn't a seat right
on time I was just like oh my god was so
embarrassing have you been recognized
from the document training kazeno it's
had limited training or seven people be
like my god you guys are like that I'm
not yeah I mean certainly yeah I don't
think it's it's been seen by a wide
enough audience I don't know wait just
wait yarmulke on it yeah yeah you'll be
stopping and starting a comic con
alberto picture hey what are you guys
looking forward to for next year's conde
very fun going right well right now we
weren't able to get tickets
yeah mom organics Morgan's made made
some promises oh right yeah you guys
think about that but the Justice
schedule ouch it's gotta be you guys are
Hall H people you're just like there's
sort of a balkanization of con these
days ideal um a lot of people like to
blame Twilight but I guess I remember
like I've been going for for about seven
years and my friend like seven years ago
we it didn't sell out you know so but
it's just more and more people have
become aware of that I mean even running
it for I think because geeks are geeks
and that's what we do we feel very like
enthusiastic / possessive about the
things we like I think if it gets some
like 12 year old girl whose only read
Twilight to become interested in
something else that's geeky you know or
like gets her into sci-fi or fantasy I
think it's a good thing and yeah it's
like it's so annoying when there's so
many people but it's it's a good thing
that happen though because one of things
I tend to worry about is that the idea
college she said you people stay all day
to get exposed to things that today
would it be exposed to otherwise but i
remember i was at wondercon one year and
the DC panel was upwards on and you had
this room full of people waiting to see
a doctor who the screening in full
doctor who regarded and the teasing
people couldn't get inside since you can
repair I mean and I don't know how much
you have any medicos of like you see
like a young girl come in for Twilight
than be with like our action figure or
something anything you see that you see
the cross polarization happen is it the
con working yeah I by I I hear you I
hear your argument and because you're
definitely because so much is going on
you definitely can just kind of make the
con is what just what you want and but
but part of you know part of that
experience is like you know in order to
get into you know that panel that you
know that that Ron panel that you really
want to go to
you know there's there's something
beforehand that you you inevitably have
to like line up for that in order to
make sure that you can get into the next
thing and kind of threw that you can
forget yeah entertainment content that
you are necessarily seeking kind of
becomes a part of it because everything
is program just kind of back to back and
I can't just like because you're some
next to so many people for so long
whether it's in line or in a seat
there's gonna be something you guys will
talk about you didn't know about where
even if you're like just kind of file it
away for later and you're not immediate
lady like I'm gonna go buy that toys
yeah I think it's like happening on the
more kind of like small local authorized
I mean I went and I had specific thing
going to cover and I when I was just
like hanging out there like dishes
foster then I cry like a super girl
shirt and house another like that I was
exposed than the girl it's supposed to
open to go to stop it was really cool
yeah now you guys actually brought up a
good point that I want to get you people
like my readers some people don't know
that because something's a college it
like for you can actually go in and I
you just hang out all day and until your
panel you guys kind of did that a little
bit so this is a question that I asked
Martha working about because it wasn't
covered in the documentary which I was
great before before you guys in Hall H
when that dude scab the energy that was
right before he proposes
were you guys in here that we were there
scary yeah anyway yeah now is love is
there ya behold two hours right yeah
everything else away thank you yeah they
could they didn't want to have carrots
in there yeah so there was a fire so
there's no way was just a scratch no no
it was having a face with a ball point
directly I was it spread around it was
in the high and we're all cracking on my
back injury the I know Chief jokes
instance when that happened did you look
at Morgan in a critical I don't know if
I want to do this today or we just like
I'm gonna do today there was definitely
like in the kind of immediate aftermath
of it of his cut I was definitely like
oh this is like and I know that they
yeah there was they they did kind of
kick out like a lot of kind of press and
and and Morgan had to kind of like yeah
because we were being followed by like
Morgan wasn't with our careers like it
was like a dozen different kind of
cruise and like that was actually kind
of my the only time I saw Morgan the
whole weekend was when he kind of came
down to Hall H to negotiate to get the
camera crew kind of back in before this
moment yeah and yeah yeah I did
definitely was kind of like oh this is
yeah yeah this is not the mood that I
want a spike by as soon as kind of
things kind of started up again and
people are like yeah this is you know
we're all here for you know you know
this this entertainment that we love you
know the the mood change pretty quickly
kind of wants things stop got going
again well your engagement was hilarious
because my best friend was at that
paneling all right y'all she's like oh
my god these people just on occasion so
funny no love interest in the film do
you incorporate any comic book role
playing into your
I'm not sure what do you think about you
like to keep some aspects of our lives
take it out of the yes he's too good
Adam 8305 rich the cattle more recently
Chico and reto which was nominated for
the Academy Award that has graphic
sexuality and animated films I think
especially with like anime tradition
there's always been like you know nan PG
animation yeah I think just like America
I started Adam Yauch up to it and like
it's good i don't think in the
animations or cartoons are just for kids
you know I think it's like such a
beautiful art form and I'm glad that
like Miyazaki's getting his films like
we release in the US like even though
it's dubbed which sucks yeah you know
you guys excited about this year sorry I
definitely excited for the hobbit at the
end of the year we got that but not da
we got to we were the first 1i trailer I
played a great time yeah what should I
had some technical difficulties and then
once they got it working there like put
it again yeah that's probably what I'm
most excited for it's like the year the
year the dwarves this year hi snow white
and the huntsman yeah and Ricky Gervais
show on HBO okay yeah life's too short
yeah that's true are you now you guys
are still in grad school I'm finishing
it limit my master did a lot in media
arts and technology studying media and
production and stuff what are your plans
after you guys obviously com always
going to be there sure you guys plan to
go into Comic Con white jobs that you
can do it hey you know don't you have I
should you have a dream of someday
having your stuff be at comic-con and
you're like in a booth and people are
lining up to get your autograph he's hot
stuff play yeah hamakawa ready I
initially kind of came to come to
comic-con as part of the
in a little short film festival and I
went to film school at NYU and like did
kind of genre I did and you know made
little Kylie Jean or short films have
played it at that film festival and I
Waldo in grad school I've been kind of
working as a TV ad TV editor as well
also yeah definitely you know paying the
bills these days but still kind of like
nursing my own little projects would you
did the film festival there there do
they still X people kind of advertise on
the show floor oh yeah absolutely hey
sure I was there with one and they would
not let anyone really yeah hey let's see
in a bit you're gonna give it your all I
really like 12 people in its gonna sober
never sighs yeah yeah yeah oh yeah the
Nugent off of all made it I years yeah
yeah okay hey I be with you